>> Sean:
>> Sean
>> President Donald Trump: NANCY
PELOSI AND THE GROUP, YOU HEARD
HERE THE OTHER DAY.
SHE WANTS TO RAISE YOUR TAXES.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE TAX
CUT BILL AND RAZE -- RAISE YOUR
TAXES.
SOMEHOW I DON'T THINK THAT PLAYS
WELL.
YOU NEVER KNOW, RIGHT.
THEY WANT TO RAISE YOUR TAXES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
BELIEVE IN BORDERS, DON'T
BELIEVE IN FIGHTING CRIME, DON'T
BELIEVE IN MAKING A STRONG
MILITARY.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN WHAT THE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM BELIEVE.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU.
SO WE HAVE TO DO A GREAT JOB.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT AT THE
SUSAN B. ANTHONY DINNER TONIGHT
WARNING US ABOUT WHAT IS TO COME
IF NANCY PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS OVER TOOK OVER
CONGRESS, DESPITE REPUBLICANS
LEADING IN A GENERIC BALLOT POLL
AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS.
CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN IS EXPOSING
THE LEFT'S PLAN IF THEY TAKE A
MAJORITY.
YOU'VE HEARD IT BEFORE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO BE A LITTLE
MORE QUIET ABOUT IT.
BUT THIS IS THEIR PLAN.
BELIEVE IT.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT THERE WILL
BE MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO WAIT
FOR SOMEONE ELSE IF THAT SOMEONE
ELSE, DOESN'T MATTER WHO IT IS,
IS DECLINING TO DO IT.
WE CAN ALL DO IT.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S A GOOD
LIKELIHOOD THERE WILL BE
ARTICLES OF I IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
SEBASTIAN GORKA, FORMER SECRET
SERVICE OFFICER, DAN BONGINO.
DAN, IT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE,
NANCY WILL GIVE IN -- PELOSI
WILL GIVE IN TO HER LEFT-WING
BASE.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES AND
BASICALLY WOULD LIKE TO STOP
THIS PRESIDENT'S SUCCESSFUL
AGENDA.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY WILL GO
FOR IMPEACHMENT REGARDLESS.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE.
>> SEAN, YOU UNDERSTAND, THEY
HAVE NOTHING ELSE, RIGHT.
THIS IS A BROKEN, DESTRUCTIVE,
DISTURBING SHELL OF A PARTY THAT
IS DROWNING IN IDENTITY POLITICS
AND RAGE AT DONALD TRUMP; THAT
IS MANIFESTING ITSELF THROUGHOUT
OUTRAGEOUS CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT
FOR FAIRYTALE COLLUSION CHARGES
NO ONE CAN PROVIDE ANY EVIDENCE
OF.
SEAN, YOU CAN'T WIN A DEMOCRAT
PRIMARY IN THESE RADICAL
FAR-LEFT CONGRESS DISTRICTS IF
YOU DON'T GO, YOU KNOW, FULL
PSYCHOPATH AND START CALLING FOR
THE IMPEACHMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
I MEAN, THEY DON'T STAND FOR IT
ANY MORE.
THE PARTY IS COMPLETELY BROKEN.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE POINT.
Dr. GORKA, JUST DON'T SAY IT.
SHH.
LET'S KEEP IT QUIET.
LET'S NOT BE HONEST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE HONEST ABOUT, YEAH,
WE'RE RUNNING ON THE PLATFORM,
LET'S RAISE EVERYBODY'S TAXES
DRAMATICALLY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS GOING TO
WORK.
>> WHAT ELSE DO THEY HAVE, SEAN,
LITERALLY.
WE WANT TO RAISE YOUR TAXES.
WHAT ELSE COULD THEY DO?
WE WANT TO, WHAT, BRING BACK
ISIS?
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WALL ISN'T BUILT.
WE WANT THE ECONOMY TO TANK.
WE DON'T WANT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE TO BE GIVEN CASH BONUSES
BECAUSE OF THE TAX REFORM.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO RUN ON.
BUT, SEAN, 2018 IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN 2016 BECAUSE IF
THEY GET THE MAJORITY, THEY WILL
BEGIN IMPEACHMENT AND ALL THE
INCREDIBLE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE IN JUST 15
MONTHS WILL BE STOPPED.
THEY WILL BE OBSTRUCTED FOR THE
NEXT SEVEN YEARS.
SO 2016 WAS AN ACT OF GOD, YES,
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FLOTILLA COMES UP BEHIND
THIS ICEBREAKER WHO IS DONALD
TRUMP AND MAKE SURE THE MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGENDA IS
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE NEXT SEVEN
YEARS.
>> Sean: THINK ABOUT THIS, IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY, A 17-POINT
DEMOCRATIC ADVANTAGE, GENERIC
BALLOT, DAN.
NOW IT'S A SIX-POINT REPUBLICAN
ADVANTAGE.
I THINK IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S
SUCCESS THAT'S TURNED THIS ALL
AROUND.
>> SEAN, PEOPLE VOTE KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES, THE FAPTNESS OF
THEIR WALLET, YOU KNOW, NOT THE
FATNESS OF FAKE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION CHARGES THEY'VE WASTED
ALL THIS TIME ON.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE LEARNED
NOTHING FROM THE IMPEACHMENT OF
BILL CLINTON AND HIS SUBSEQUENT
WIN IN THE SENATE THERE IN THAT
THAT TRIAL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO NOT WANT
THE RESULTS OF A FAIR AND SOUND
ELECTION OVERTURNED BY A BUNCH
OF POLITICIANS UP ON CAPITOL
HILL.
THIS IS A TACTICALLY RIDICULOUS
MOVE THAT IS GOING TO -- THE
BLOW BACKWILL BE SUBSTANTIAL IF
THEY DO THIS.
>> Sean: DOCTOR, WHAT IS YOUR
TAKE?
LOOK, I'VE BEEN SAYING, AND I'VE
REALLY -- I HAVE A LOT OF PLANS
FOR THIS AUDIENCE COMING UP IN
THE DAYS, WEEKS AND MONTHS
AHEAD.
DON'T WANT TO REVEAL MY PLANS.
A LOT OF COPYCATS AND UNCREATIVE
PEOPLE IN TELEVISION AND RADIO.
HERE'S MY POINT, THIS WILL BE A
DEFINING, HISTORIC MOMENT, THIS
MIDTERM ELECTION, THE MOST
IMPORTANT MIDTERM PERHAPS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT AN ELECTION TO DESTROY
THIS PRESIDENT.
THAT IS ALL THEY HAVE, THAT AND
RAISING TAXES AND GUTTING OUR
MILITARY.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY STAND FOR, BUT
THEY WON'T EVEN BE HONEST WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THAT
AGENDA.
>> OBAMA ADMITTED, SEAN, HE
WANTS TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
AMERICA.
YOU DON'T FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
SOMETHING YOU LOVE.
THIS IS OUR WINDOW.
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY.
THERE'S A VERY SMALL WINDOW NOW
TO BRING IT ALL BACK, TO BRING
BACK THE REPUBLIC, THE STAKES
COULD NOT BE HIGHER.
THEY WANT TO DIVIDE US.
THEY WANT TO UNDERMINE US.
IT IS ONLY THE MIDTERMS THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
SAVE THE REPUBLIC.
IT'S SIMPLY THAT MASSIVE A STAKE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: DAN, AND YOU AGREE?
>> YEAH, I AGREE.
THEY'VE LEARNED NOTHING, THE
DEMOCRATS, FROM THEIR LOSS IN
WISCONSIN, PENNSYLVANIA AND
NEARLY IN MINNESOTA AS WELL.